[Music]
not my fault news that me submitted by
I'm from Houston Texas no southern
accent beau hey howdy we'll handle it
for you they said no I know what a true
y'all a transgender boy who won the
girls state wrestling title for the
second time was booed by the crowd
exchanged to say that one not take this
as a joke that I would enter as a 90
pound weight class female in boxing this
teenager is 18 year old born a girl
talking to a boy it's forced to wrestle
in the girls division forced because
they're saying this rule that you have
to go by whatever on whatever is on your
birth certificate I see he has been
taking low dosages of testosterone
that's not good Oh apples on steroids
yeah that's not fair people are saying
like that's not fair that's not fair but
are they booing oh I mean him because
cuz that fools on steroids but it's not
it's not his fault
not everyone's being forced not everyone
is gonna gonna have that because all
they see is some personal body slamming
the [ __ ] better their daughters let's
uh this is max bag so oh [ __ ] he has won
for the second year in a row what what's
what's their name
Mac Mac Beth his his I don't know his
hey I'm telling you it's Mac Beth right
bags bags all right I'm just gonna say
Beck's cuz i refuse to [ __ ] get
confused it's just his name is max
I'm not gonna refer to them by that PO
now I'm just gonna say their name and so
this is the second time second year in a
row that he's won the girls a hundred
and ten pounds of Italy's girls class
yeah that dude is yoked right but he's
being forced he has an undefeated record
of course I'm gonna show you guys the
clip if you're taking steroids if you're
taking steroids you're not supposed to
be allowed in the league
yes but because a healthcare
professional is administering who's a
dumb asteroid and because it's like for
a medical purpose it's okay like oh my
bad pretty sure they came in you've
gotta do this
well you're discriminating then Oh so
that's kinda like I got a broken arm
give me steroids but that's not like
long terms and this seems like cosmetic
I mean whatever he's a senior but he's
been taking load those stitches of
testosterone since he was a freshman
like 4 years ago so he's been on gear
for 4 years yeah because I'm listening
from a sports standpoint I don't really
give a [ __ ] about like transgender
social issues whatever I'm gonna do I'm
sensitive to that but I'm trying to
examine it from a sports athletics
perspective which is probably why a lot
of parents are pissed and if you've been
on gear for four years you can get a lot
of gains which is [ __ ] crazy
yeah he'll [ __ ] up dudes in the same
weight class I'm sure if it was up to
him he would love you in the guy he's
been begging and yeah are you saying no
it's the administration's fault because
he's not trying to [ __ ] up a bunch of
girls like what the [ __ ] he's not waking
up every morning saying like you know
what I do you think you've necessarily
proud of these wins legally it's also
not his fault cuz for him he's like I'm
passionate about wrestling and it's the
league that's putting my opponents in
front of me yeah so it's like if the
league wants to put children in front of
me well I just guess out of beat the
[ __ ] out that's true cuz he can't choose
the opponent's
exactly cuz last year or last season put
me in the senior league ah [ __ ] those
[ __ ] grannies
[ __ ] grandma is dead I would love to
take stories of drama do you guys know
of a fighting fighting looks like a UFC
is rising the Japanese one oh yeah yeah
did you guys see that match of the
[ __ ] lie roided-out chick fighting the
grandma no no no they rise and put
together a match where there was his
grandma that fought somebody who looked
like cyborg why Japanese leads they were
[ __ ] crazy was the grandma like a
martial artist though no she was
bouncing off the wrestling wheels like
it was WWE like she just came up a
clocker and just started smashing happen
but that's what this reminds me of right
now you know it's funny about those
Japanese leagues it's like you know that
they love entertainment so much yeah
there are the only league where the
referee is hooked up with like 20
cameras dude yeah like this like this
will have to worry about getting the
right shot no in America it's like let's
call the sport make sure everyone's safe
for them it's like let's get every
single angle and not it's different
because out here it's sportsmanship like
even you have seen all those it's very
technical and logical yeah but in Japan
it's about the fight story it's about
the passion in the fight and sometimes
they don't have to be the most athletic
but it's like look at this guy's
determinate entertainment he's lost ten
times in a row here he goes again you'd
be out of a league in America right yeah
but then it's like they build it up
where it's super emotional and it's like
this guy just cannot win
on this ad applause today is going to be
a good day yeah so bags are saying that
he faced two forfeits last season and in
this season he faced one forfeit wear
the coat the opposing coach and
teammates they were insisting the girls
[ __ ] that I throw it no they were
insisting her to wrestle Mac but then
the girl was like nope I'm not doing it
yeah but those arms though man
websites are I did wrestle I did wrestle
in high school and there are some girls
that are hella good so in the states
where wrestling isn't as big as like
these states where they have all guy
wrestling and all girls
it's usually unisex and in some of those
unisex leaks the girls will have to
wrestle guys and I've seen girls like
wipe the floor with guys before - oh
there's unisex leaks Wow
the majority of them are probably
intersect it's only the big wrestling
states where it's not there's enough
people who I don't want to take place in
Texas all the states were they got jack
[ __ ] to do have full-on girls
full-on guys but in California it's it's
you know thing for me when I was
expecting to see the picture I thought
that one tenor was gonna look very gaunt
and slim
however the person's arms is 130 yeah
legit thought I did not think that
person was 110 I'll show you guys his
victory where he's getting any mauled
the person is a video he's pretty far
along a trailer shows you so here we go
that's a big tournament that is huge
of course Wow
[Music]
that is a big-ass [ __ ] tournament
they're really about it because it's
Texas huh these are parents booing a
teenage child what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you shut the [ __ ] up
you know what's pretty cool though I
love watching rest it's like one of my
favorite Olympic sports to watch yeah
just because like if you just look at
something like that just like the the
hip dexterity and the spine flexibility
of that [ __ ] was amazing yeah yeah you
remind me of fishes out of water it's so
[ __ ] cool there's so many wiggling
yeah well we were uh we're up one night
one night and then we're just watching
random recipe said it like that what the
[ __ ] what I'll try to find another words
I don't repeat words by foot or just
want randomly watching wrestling man I
missed that stuff it's tight
I just sound like you were hiding
something oh I bet you're gonna end it
with like you body slam sharing sports
were like wait so we you know on the TV
yeah go from volleyball the best
available or like sharing on high school
sports with each other oh yeah wrestlers
are pretty pretty amazing they're like
just in just as like the physicality of
a wrestler and how strong they are some
of them don't even look that strong but
whatever that conditioning is their grip
strength is amazing that we were talking
about this last week so like you have
like tubes that go into wrestling who
are wrestlers they'll go into beat like
BJJ and like they have trouble dealing
with them yeah just if you just look at
it it's just hard to take down a [ __ ]
wrestler especially how hard they shoot
in the grip strength it's [ __ ]
ridiculous of course like well
somebody's on their back and they're
doing BJJ it's like it's a different
story but like I I like I respect
wrestlers like all the way up here
that's pretty amazing people you know
the guy Eddie Bravo started a 10th
planet jiu-jitsu yeah so he's like a
really prolific a modern-day like BJJ
teacher and the reason why his school
does so good is he takes the wrestling
approach to BJJ so BJJ what they do like
martial arts is usually it's like more
philosophical a new practice technique
they don't drill but a wrestling it's
like shot shot shot yeah drill it like
hardcore it's all about repetition and
then he took that into VJ June which is
why his schools like kill on time I miss
judo
[Music]
throwing someone your weight or lighter
is one of the most satisfying feelings I
think it's even better than striking
someone but when you get a really good
leverage on someone and you [ __ ] toss
them and put your ass into their [ __ ]
chest that kind of ties back into their
previous statement of wanting a feet up
pitches now weights a beautiful girl
account weight to throw my weight or
lighter
well I've tossed people that were bigger
but it's not as satisfying because they
don't they don't fly uh-oh they're so
big you just kind of bump up and then
big kind of rolls out it's a balance
thing yeah I like learning I mean not I
like I said I like learning how I'm like
some things you just don't see when
you're watching and when you actually
experience it it's like holy [ __ ] like
like David with a sumo wrestler I had no
idea that were that [ __ ] fast and
flexible and big and big that's true cuz
when you're on stage you look at an
erect sick dude yeah dude when I was
next to him I like dude I look good oh
you didn't hit a sandwich yeah I was
like cuz you saw them from a distance
right and so what I walked up next to a
bus like my god disappeared into his
body
yeah elbows deep like what the [ __ ] and
it's crazy because like they were so
flexible there's a whatsit [ __ ] but then
I had no idea how like I guess like
dense they aren't how fast they were -
like when they came charging at you
I cried free I mean they're athletes so
like even when he grabbed my wrist he
threw me I thought him was at a man [ __ ]
no Japanese waiver yeah if you're trying
so hard you didn't even vote it's two
things he's [ __ ] strong he's really
flexible and on top of that I just
started getting absorbed like it was
just elbows in at that point yeah that's
crazy
I'd no idea
[Music]
[Music]